Alex has just completed his graduation
from Stanford University
one fine day he receives a mail from
Star Trek Technologies for an interview
for the designation of a software
engineer as referred by the University
Alex was really happy and excited about
this and starts preparing for his
interview next week while he was
preparing Alex came across the term
downtime
Alex has no idea what is a downtime
he decided to seek help from his uncle
John a software engineer
John explained that downtime is a
specific time frame allocated to deploy
or update changes for a software product
in a real-time environment and this
happens because most of the softwares we
use today are developed using the
waterfall model
for example Cisco one of the popular
leaders in it and networking globally is
using agile methodology for their
subscription billing platform SBP as it
was originally developed using the
waterfall model
after adopting the agile methodology
Cisco's product improved its overall
efficiency where defects were reduced by
40 percent compared to the previous
releases and effect removal efficiency
increased by 14
upon explaining what downtime is John
further added that downtime is a small
part of the waterfall model
it is the traditional way of developing
softwares using a software development
lifecycle where the whole product is
treated as one single unit and the
development of one phase starts only
after the completion of the previous
phase adding new features or updating
the existing feature in a waterfall
model based product needs a specific
time frame known as downtime to avoid
disturbance in the workflow of an
organization we're applying changes in a
waterfall-based product might produce
irrelevant results or product failure
the waterfall model is the earliest or
the traditional model used for software
development or the output of one phase
acts as the input for the preceding
phase consisting of a series of steps
where each phase has specific
deliverables that act as the input for
the next phase as it avoids overlapping
phases as these phases are dependent on
each other
this method is simple and easy to
understand where prerequisites are
pre-known documented earlier and
Technology remains static where there is
no need for ambiguous requirements due
to the delay in software delivery in
contrast the final version is available
only after completing the entire
software lifecycle process with any
deviations if available
changes in the waterfall model contain
high risk as changes include a new
revised version of the entire software
running the entire series of steps again
and again
for example a tap and pay machine where
the machine first validates whether the
customer's account is funded with
sufficient funds or not and then
initiates the transaction for money
transfer unless the validation is
processed the transaction cannot be
initiated
Alex was curious and asked Uncle John is
there any way to overcome the drawbacks
of the waterfall model
John replies yes agile methodology was
introduced to overcome the problems
faced in the waterfall model where agile
based products are developed by breaking
the entire product process into
microservices or phases which is faster
to execute and deploy changes on the go
there is no need to worry about other or
previous tasks while working on one
particular phase avoiding product
failure to deploy changes unlike the
waterfall model where the whole product
is treated as one single unit and each
process is dependent on the preceding
processes where deploying changes leads
to downtime how agile products are
developed agile based products are
developed using the agile life cycle at
first the develop product will working
environment for reviews from clients and
stakeholders to check its deliverables
and functionality after client reviews
the official product is launched in a
real-time working environment where
agile methodology focuses on satisfying
the consumer needs by efficiently
utilizing the resources and avoiding
additional risks or deviations in the
product for example providing a trial
beta version of the software for the end
user to experience the software towards
its deliverables and results will be
helpful in refining and reviewing the
product like Adobe Photoshop Adobe
Illustrator
Etc
after understanding all about agile
methodology Alex asks Uncle John for
companies implementing agile on their
workspace nowadays John replies yes
companies are moving towards agile
methodology due to its flexibility and
advantages over traditional systems by
adopting agile for their Sony
interactive environment Sony noticed a
major difference where there was a
reduced planning Time by 28 with their
framework and which made the company
save 30 million dollars a year so here's
a question for you what makes agile
different from waterfall Model A it is
dependent on microservices B Agile
consumes more time
C the process is broken down into
several phases d none of the above
please give it a thought and post your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive Amazon
gift vouchers
agile methodology aims to meet the
consumer's requirements to the Mac besto
principles brings an Innovative set of
rules and protocols to help developers
overcome the challenges faced in the
traditional practices waterfall model
making agile flexible and efficient
welcome to Agile tutorial from Simply
learn I am CMR Chandra Mr a professional
consultant and coach certified agile
scrum Master PMP Princeton practitioner
itl for managing professional kobit 5
and devops as part of this video
tutorial we are going to understand what
is agile the basic details one should
know about a child
to understand this better let us look at
a time in the late 90s what was
happening with software development
forms
so they used to follow waterfall
methodologies
so there used to be expression like sir
you have a problem so what happened so
our client want a new feature to the
software we are already Midway creating
the software we can't add the feature so
what does it mean so there is a scenario
where the change is asked so why change
change may be because of adding certain
features removing certain features
modifying certain things already given
what is wrong in that why can't we do
the change so now Point here is not
about doing the change itself it's about
the effort additionally it takes cost
money in terms of which is going out the
effort then the scope which is going to
change at the same time you also need to
put more efforts which will delay the
project
so now is it okay so 90s it was okay
today is it okay a big question mark so
why is that not okay so may it
understand that very clearly right I
knew we should not have used the
waterfall methodology for development so
is that an issue with the waterfall
methodology
so answer is no if it is today's
scenario answer would be S if it is 90s
answer would be no
so what changed in this 20 years or 15
years the Dynamics of the market changed
the behavior of consumers changed so if
you look at anyone who is using any
product it may be a software product or
a hardware
like if your mobile phone or a
television or any application mobile
application or application used on your
systems the upgradation of the new
features and functionality of that is
improved more and more and consumer
wants it more and you have a very less
time to respond that is one thing second
thing there is lot of competition if you
do not respond quickly computation will
take over so for you to sustain and grow
it is very essential that you understand
this Dynamics and you need to respond
quickly which was bit difficult when it
comes to approach what is called
waterfall model
now how do we address this so what is
that waterfall model is all about why is
it difficult for us so the methodology
where waterfall model is used involves
teams following a series of steps and
only going forward after the previous
steps are completed so there is a wait
time involved so until the previous
steps are completed only then I can move
to the next so it is a slower thing it
would take certain longer duration so it
is best used in the scenarios where the
teams are small and the project is
expected to move in a predictable manner
so predictability is very important when
we follow waterfall methodology
predictability the variation should be
as lesser as possible so what is the
predictability I'm speaking about as I
create this product as a result comes up
if it takes six months one year two
years three years it's okay so this is
how the product would look like the
predictability how the product would
look like how that particular output
would come so when is that going to to
come is it okay if I bring that result
after two years is that okay so if
everything is okay that way without very
less without any variations as such very
less variations then it's fine
so because of following waterfall model
uh what is that methodology what is that
flow and that so requirements Gathering
and documentation is the first thing
what used to happen which is true in
agile methodologies also but the main
difference here is the requirements
Gathering and documentation move to the
design
now based on that requirement which is
gathered then the design will happen
based on that the consideration of
process the products the people the
environment then the design happens
which is again a detailed design
now once the implementation starts if
you find any deviations the correction
needs to be done since the design is in
detail the deviation possibilities as
less as possible
but the challenge comes up when the
Dynamics in the market when the Dynamics
of customer changes customer asks for
change then you may require to do the
change now when you want to do the
change you may require to do the change
only after understanding what would be
the impact of this change in the entire
output which you are going to create
which is very comprehensive one so
because of this it consumes time it
consumes extra effort so it may be a
scenario where the scope of work is
reduced as well even after that this
exercise has to be done which will delay
the project so this was okay so when
this model when things were done things
were taken up for changes it was okay
because the consumer Behavior as I
mentioned there is a lot of wait time
for the consumers also so there was less
competition but today it is not I need
to go quicker so because of this what
are the disadvantages which is came up
who actually follow waterfall
methodology so what so then it doesn't
focus on inducer client customer
perspective value so today I think more
and more we're speaking about creating a
value in the consumer prospective
customer perspective and the time it
takes for Consumer to realize the value
how long it takes the more it delays in
realizing the values by the consumer
there is a delay in terms of making your
product impression better in the
consumer's mind so computation will take
over so your existence will be in bigger
threat so testing phase is delayed until
most of the project is completed because
it has to follow step by step weight the
things to complete and then testing
happen then measuring the progress
within the stages is difficult so why is
it difficult measuring the progress
within the stages because the
deliverables or the metrics what are
defined are defined to measure at a
milestone and at a end of the phase to
understand whether everything is
delivered as part of it
now let us look at how agile is going to
help us to address these disadvantages
mentioned in waterfall model so what is
agile the basic meaning of agile is to
move faster be flexible respond to
change Etc but to accomplish this there
are a lot of methodologies now there is
something called agile Manifesto and 12
principles of agile which we need to
understand so following this
accomplishing this can only help us in
becoming agile
so in 2001 agile was introduced so
that's why it's used so agile Manifesto
was also released it's a set of
principles used in project management
and software development so basically
there are four points which we need to
understand very correctly very clearly
so that we can able to understand what
is agile is all about right it enables
team to deliver value to their customers
with ease so agile team deliver working
small but usable increments then
evaluation of the requirements plans and
results takes place continuously this
allows teams to respond to changes
quickly now change was one of the
scenario what we were speaking about now
responding to change quickly is one of
the disadvantages what we spoke about
and here it is addressed it is
considered to address that is very
important now when we respond to change
quickly it is not that I just quickly
responded but I did not address that
problem or that scenario it is very
essential to address that scenario as
well effectively and efficiently so now
agile is a concept right so it has a
detailed Manifesto based on which all
the agile methodologies are created so
what is this agile Manifesto is all
about so it is created it was created
during February 2001 so which details
out the values and principles of agile
processes which says there are some
values which is mentioned in the left
which has more weightage compared to the
one which is in the right now when we
say this for example let us take let us
go individuals and interactions over
process and tools so are we saying we
don't value the process and tools that
is not the case now let us look at what
were the typical issues or challenges
anyone would have expressed regarding
the processes so delay may be